[Musica]
facciamo un salto nel tempo siamo nella
Treviso degli anni 30 c'è una signora
austriaca che per motivi diversi si è
trovato a vivere qui in questa comunità
e
ha sposato un italiano si è trasferita e
per motivi che riguardano poi la sua
vita finisce con l'essere ricoverato nel
manicomio di Treviso di sant'artemio
Appunto
questa signora che era rimasta vedova
aveva avuto dei grandi difficoltà è una
signora come ce la possiamo immaginare
una signora della buona borghesia degli
anni 30 diventa l'istruttrice di tedesco
della loro direttore del manicomio Luigi
Zanon dal bo' e
ha una speranza vorrebbe tornare in
Austria gli piacerebbe tornare nel suo
paese perché qui Ormai non ha più molto
da fare
scoppia la guerra succedono tutte le
cose che sappiamo che succedono
improvvisamente il primo di agosto del
1944 si presenta una aitante ufficiale
tedesco alla sant'artemio di Treviso e
dice la signora venga con me che le
riporto in Austria Peccato che
l'ufficiale tedesco fosse franzhang già
direttore dei campi di concentramento di
tre Blink e agli altri posti e che
insieme con lei porto via quattro
persone
come si diceva allora giudaiche e poi
dalla signora non sarebbero più notizie
la signora quando arrivò stanca andando
via con grande fiducia
con Grande entusiasmo pensando che il
suo desiderio si fosse realizzato Ecco
che parlando del mio punto di vista
inevitabilmente quando ho sentito la
parola il tema di questa serata ho
pensato a cosa c'era di contrario Noi
siamo abituati noi psichiatri intendo
dire siamo abituati a vedere il
controllo delle cose la faccio oscura
della Luna certo la fiducia Il sospetto
se la signora brutta avesse avuto
qualche sospetto probabilmente non lo
avrebbe potuto fare niente Però la sua
vissuta emotivo sarebbe stato
completamente diverso di quella vicenda
sono cambiate le cose allora sono
cambiate molto
augurabilmente la SS non ci sono più e
non ci saranno mai più ce lo vogliamo
tutti i manicomi sicuramente non ci sono
più e non ci saranno più ce lo auguriamo
tutti sono stati chiusi nel 1978 con una
percorso che Tutti conoscono che è stato
importante significativo siamo l'unico
paese al mondo Che tuttora non ha più
quei grandi istituti no che
ricoveravano i cosiddetti delle persone
come diceva la legge è pericolosa se
agli altri o di pubblico scandalo e le
ricoveravano contro la loro volontà
sempre in maniera obbligatoria sono
cambiate le cose però Dal 1978 sono
cambiate le cose Completamente cambiata
la comunità viviamo in un mondo che è
completamente diverso non è più lo
stesso
Allora si fece il grande passo di
pensare che le persone ricoverate in
quegli istituti dovessero essere incluse
nella comunità
la legge tutt'oggi è assolutamente in
vigore coerente valida però la comunità
profondamente cambiata
se per un momento voi vi immaginate una
persona che ha un grosso disturbo
mentale che insomma immaginatela come
volete
avete un modo di pensare un'immagine
un'idea che Lasciatemi dire spesso è un
po' pregiudiziale no si Immagina la
persona con un disturbo mentale come
diversa altra aliena
ce la si Immagina bizzarra strana c'è un
bel quadro di Picasso che
rappresenta appunto Il Folle come la
persona trasandata trascurata così come
sono immaginiamo non una persona che ha
perso il contatto col mondo beh non è
così il contatto col mondo non è perso
nessuno le persone continuano a essere
persone
indipendentemente dal problema oggi lo
sappiamo sappiamo che è così Certo che
le persone in generale ragionano Come si
dice hanno i loro schemi cognitivi le
loro idee
quello che si chiama un po' una
psicologia popolare il senso comune
facciamo giudizi abbiamo valutazioni che
spesso non hanno a che fare con la
realtà ma hanno a che fare con la
velocità con cui noi pensiamo No noi
pensiamo intuitivamente automaticamente
ad alcune cose
sono stati fatti degli studi molto
interessanti per esempio per capire
cos'è che influenzava certi giudici
nell'emettere i verdetti Perché i
verdetti dei giudici hanno così diversi
Beh insomma
tante cose non vesto qui a dire tutte ma
quello che a me colpito che mi sembra
molto interessante per esempio che c'era
grande differenza fra i verdetti prima
di pranzo e dopo pranzo oppure se aveva
vinto non aveva vinto la squadra del
cuore Questo è un po' Lo capisco ma
insomma in generale
fattori che uno pensa non dovrebbero
così influire ma è così per tutti se voi
fate un piccolo incidente stradale per
esempio
pensate che
insomma era colpa di chi vi è venuto
addosso oppure il marciapiede che l'ha
messo male eccetera se lo stesso
coincidente lo fa un'altra persona
pensate E che cavolo Quello non sa
guidare è una persona assolutamente
incapace sono schemi che noi applichiamo
no E così come applichiamo questi schemi
ai giudizi che diamo sulle cose spesso
li applichiamo appunto all'idea di come
funziona la nostra mente questa è la
psicologia Popolare cioè l'idea che noi
abbiamo del perché gli altri fanno
quello che fanno
Ecco la psichiatria in questi anni
dovrebbe essere cambiata è cambiata in
parte è cambiata Nel senso che si è
posto il problema di dare spiegazioni
diverse da questa psicologia Popolare
però è difficile è molto difficile dire
come funziona la mente perché la mente
di persona una cosa complessa In primo
luogo la mente può essere studiata
come esperienza personale lo fanno i
poeti lo fanno gli artisti che esprimono
quello che sentono la mente può essere
studiata
attraverso sistemi scientifici No
nel remaging o strutture di questo tipo
che in qualche maniera
identificano la mente con il cervello ma
la mente In realtà è qualcosa che sta
nella relazione fra persone e ciò che
sta nella relazione tra persone non sono
i cervelli sono le persone e le persone
sono un corpo un cervello e tutto quello
che ci va intorno come ci dicono tanti
neuro scienziati molto famosi e molto
bravi dicono che noi abbiamo una
dimensione emotiva e l'emozione è una
cosa che sta nel nostro corpo e da
questo corpo poi si arriva al cervello
che ha la funzione di
permettere che queste emozioni che
sentiamo poi si associno alle nostre
cognizioni al nostro modo di concepire
al nostro modo di pensare
Ecco credo che ci sia un tentativo di
salto di qualità nel nel pensiero sui
disturbi mentali che però certe volte è
un po' ostacolato dei pregiudizi che le
comunità le comunità anche dicevo sono
cambiate sono cambiate molto sono
cambiate molto in 50 anni
io non ho mai lavorato nel manicomio per
fortuna mia
però da quando ho cominciato il mio
lavoro negli anni 80 e i primi anni 80
sicuramente sono cambiati i bisogni sono
cambiate le persone in maniera radicale
ci sono state delle rivoluzioni
Incredibili La presenza dell'era
digitale per esempio che intorno al 2000
ha cambiato completamente il modo di
relazionarsi delle persone i nativi
digitali che sono i ragazzi che sono
nati sapendo che esisteva già Appunto
una cultura digitale dentro questa
cultura digitale
ma non solo sono cambiate è cambiata
l'economia sono cambiate la
disponibilità di risorse l'offerta di
lavoro la solidarietà sociale sono
cambiate infinite cose e in questi anni
oggi
la salute mentale torna ad essere ed è
una questione molto importante Lui è
sempre stato l'ho sempre stata ma è
stata sempre un po' sottovalutata e
continua Purtroppo ad essere
sottovalutata ma
credo che insomma non sarebbe sbagliato
fermare non sarebbe sbagliato
convincersi che questa cosa Invece una
cosa che un po' riguarda tutti una
comunità che non si interessa della
propria salute mentale
una nazione una regione
un'umanità che non si interessa la
propria salute mentale sta trascurando
un aspetto di sé davvero importante
davvero fondamentale
cosa è successo in questi ultimi anni è
successo che c'è stato il covip che
adesso ci sono 20 di guerra che c'è una
grande instabilità però a dire il vero
già una decina di anni fa una quindicina
di anni fa c'erano alcuni che parlavano
di un'epoca di passioni tristi di uno
svuotamento di senso di difficoltà a
trovare quella spinta Vitale quel senso
di appartenenza la propria vita e di
vitalità che in qualche modo Sembrava
aver caratterizzato anche altri periodi
non sto dicendo le solite cose che
dicono le persone una certa età i miei
tempi era meglio non è così ogni ogni
epoca i suoi problemi e le sue
difficoltà Ecco bisogna concentrarsi
molto sulle difficoltà sui problemi di
questa epoca perché sono diversi da
quelli di allora
E allora oggi se dobbiamo augurarci dei
cambiamenti se dobbiamo avere speranza
come si diceva prima vi ricordo che la
speranza come dice Mark Block è una
attesa di un evento positivo ed è
esattamente il contrario dell'angoscia
dell'ansia che l'attesa di qualcosa di
negativo che non si sa definire e noi
sappiamo quanto l'ansia si è diffusa
quanto l'angoscia si diffuse Grazie a
questo dico se deve cambiare qualcosa
Certamente deve cambiare nel fatto che
riusciamo a riconoscere i problemi
che possiamo riconoscerli per la loro
autorità per la loro qualità e per il
fatto di essere problemi di persone oggi
quando nel mio lavoro si fa diagnosi una
persona arriva Racconta una storia
un'esperienza un'emozione quello che ha
sentito e in qualche maniera esce con
una diagnosi la diagnosi è fatta dei
manuali manuali sono sostanzialmente
delle probabilità statistiche che
comportamenti
o emozioni corrispondono a un certo
quadro uso grafico Che vuol dire a una
malattia specifica Beh vi assicuro che
la diagnosi è nello stesso tempo la
croce La Delizia di questo lavoro fare
diagnosi certe volte significa dare un
nome o etichettare quello che succede
una persona può essere anche
rassicurante ma nello stesso tempo
lascia perdere qualcosa che appartiene
alla dimensione propria a quel vivere in
prima persona quello che la persona
appunto è c'è qualcosa di
intrinsecamente inspiegabile
nell'esperienza individuale
tanti neuro scienziati che si occupano
di questo problema dicono potremmo
spiegare quello che vogliamo dei nostri
atti cognitivi delle nostre percezioni
delle strategie comportamentali
dell'attività motoria possiamo spiegare
tutto quello ma è una cosa che non
riusciamo ancora a spiegare che è il
vero problema difficile e che cosa si
prova ad essere se stessi perché quello
che si prova ad essere se stessi lo sa
solo fare la prova in un certo senso e
noi per allargamento possiamo pensare
Ecco che la relazione la relazione umana
è un'apertura
il tempo non mi concede ovviamente di
parlare di tutte le problematiche che ci
sono dentro la relazione e ma mi
permette di dire semplicemente una cosa
riallacciandomi un po' quello che dicevo
prima
la costruzione della fiducia della
fiducia fra persone o della fiducia nei
gruppi o della fiducia
diciamo nella massa che sarebbe un'altra
dimensione interessante è una
costruzione estremamente complessa
perché
spesso l'altra dimensione quella
contraria quella del sospetto Oppure
quella della sfiducia la sfiducia
ricorda un po' la depressione il
sospetto ricorda un po' la paranoia sono
comunque presenti sempre Non solo in Chi
ha disturbi mentali ma anche come
atteggiamenti emotivi che possono in
qualche maniera essere d'intralcio a una
qualità della relazione Allora se c'è
speranza per un futuro ci deve sempre
speranza in futuro altrimenti saremmo
tutti depressi e penseremo che non sia
più niente da fare che non c'è soluzione
che tutto colpa di questo è colpa
dell'altro se c'è speranza in un futuro
c'è anche nella consapevolezza della
comunità del proprio della propria
identità dei propri cambiamenti della
propria capacità di stabilire nuove
relazioni con nuove modalità oggi uno
dei grandi problemi sociali
è per esempio l'uso di sostanze questo
quanto questo ha cambiato l'esperienza
dei giovani in particolare delle persone
oppure Uno potrebbe dire perché ci si
dimentica sempre di tutte le
problematiche di non autonomia di
deterioramento mentale degli anziani
Oppure delle persone che sono sole che
sono ritirate pensate quanti ragazzi per
esempio non lavorano in un e non
studiano ci sono dati impressionanti da
questo punto di vista
Ecco questi sono dei nuovi bisogni delle
nuove necessità con cui la salute
mentale si deve confrontare vedo con con
grande soddisfazione che il tempo qui
davanti è arrivato ai 50 secondi questo
mi permette di salutarvi e di augurare
buon proseguimento e grazie per la
vostra attenzione
[Applauso]